playwatchlisten is supported by patreon
who actually got this episode unedited
early and AD free if you want to support
the podcast check the link in the
description uh it's been
like a month since we lasted this show I
think
I don't think we did an episode in April
did we
um since then am I done like right at
the start yes okay we've all been a bit
busy haven't we we have been a little
bit busy but since then you've had a
game come out
yes how did that go tell me about it it
went good it went good yeah
um
turns out people like the way I write
Trump so that's cool was that like
specific feedback surprise
oh yeah though the reviews have been
incredibly generous
um yeah no it's uh there's there's been
a really good reaction to it like from
the writing definitely which I I can
take a lot of credit for but also just
like the Aesthetics of it and the kind
of the World building stuff like which
obviously the whole team uh contributed
to is just yeah people seem to dig it
which is really cool it's really nice
and and exciting for future stuff
um Disney kind of
semi-accidentally announced that we were
doing more stuff the day before the game
launched oh so cool okay that's exciting
so that's cool it's yeah it's nice to
have that out there it's weird it's the
first time I've ever been kind of
developing a game with you know the
audience knowing what we're doing which
is interesting
um what do you mean like you don't
we've never really announced stuff that
early out most of our announcements are
like six months before launch at the
most
you know wow so yeah I guess that's
being like having people just know I'm
working on Tron now is cool it's
interesting does that put pressure on
um less so now that we've done one I
think I think the first one was like
definitely like intimidating because I
knew the um like the fan base
um you know obviously had been like
wanting a Tron thing for a while and
there was a bit that felt like pressure
like because they were very like you
know generous again with like when we
announced and stuff
but um no the way they kind of
they have rallied around it and been
really like they're into what we're
doing so it feels like the wins in our
sales basically which is cool
um just don't [__] it up basically it's
the uh it's the goal anyway right also
sorry I'm sick this is the third time
we've been sick this year just keeps
happening
um that's why my voice sounds terrible
it's fine
um as you reflect on this process
is there anything that like particularly
stands out is different that you can
talk about regarding working with Disney
versus every other
game you've worked on
um it's just more meetings that's kind
of what I would expect
you know what like it's not crazy though
like I think people when I talk to like
buddies in the industry about it like I
think people assume like it's very kind
of like claustrophobic and and it's much
more kind of collaborative genuinely
like I wouldn't
there's no reason to be dishonest about
that like it definitely
it feels with this if it's really felt
like just everyone wanted to make a good
thing and and now as we're doing you
know more stuff that's kind of
continuing and it's it's yeah it's
it's just been it's been weird but I
think what is I mean even when you're
working with you know
a mega company like Disney like
ultimately you're still just working
with creative people like really like
there's there's like you know obviously
there's like
Executives and meetings and you know
people in big expensive conference rooms
I have to impress every uh you know few
months or so but like the the day-to-day
of it is just like really talented smart
interesting people trying to solve
problems which is ultimately what both
of us are in this form it's a good point
like I think probably before I started
working in SMS I would have assumed that
it also contained some suits
um and it kind of doesn't uh it's not
that the suits don't exist at Sony
obviously that's like literally in order
to have fun suits know to leave you to
it though yeah and I think at SMS
there's nobody that I talk to every day
that our producers are obviously very
good at what they do and very important
about keeping people on track but even
they are like wow that's a really cool
idea wow I'm excited about this thing um
yeah and I think I probably would have
expected that like from the outside to
be
more or less creative people but I would
say 100 of the team is like that which
is super interesting it's yeah
and that's the big thing for me is like
just as and this is very true as like
dude who owns indie game Studio it's
really hard
um basically to find new people to learn
from like basically you have hiring and
business partners those are the like in
the work kind of context like it's all
like you can move companies and kind of
learn new things on new jobs and stuff
like I'm basically locked in I'm I'm
Bethel games right that's that's that is
what it is and and therefore the best
ways for me to learn are basically
either to hire really clever people
which I do as regularly as I can
um but also stuff like this where
working with Disney has just allowed me
to go into a bunch of rooms and just
yeah just just talk to people and learn
just stuff and and obviously attach to
Disney and Disney games and then Tron
specifically there's just all of this
really all this talented kind of
storytellers writers artists you know
and there's just there's a lot of
opportunity there's just kind of soak
stuff up and learn stuff and and the
best thing is it's this um it's this
kind of uh this education that's very
focused because it's focused on a thing
you're making together I did I didn't
realize it at the time but like
genuinely weirdly like
really weird premonition for like um
future stuff for me was there's a
there's a there used to be a games event
in um Nottingham called game city which
was which was really awesome it's really
special event and and tied to the museum
that's still there and does awesome work
um they they I made where May Thomas Was
Alone initially it kind of came out it
was like a a modest kind of success
Thomas is definitely one that I built
over time when it first came out it was
it was okay did okay
um and they didn't really they wanted me
to do something on this event but they
couldn't come up with kind of what to do
but they knew they wanted like a lot of
content and there wasn't much so the
pitch I gave them was like at the end 20
something idiot was can we do a thing
where every day of the conf of the event
which was like a week we do a
post-mortem with someone else kind of
giving me feedback on my game like I
just get I get the game to them they
play it and then on stage they just like
tear it apart creatively and we kind of
talk about the decisions that were made
and the kindness it was
it was so cool it's the kind of thing I
could never do now and I don't know if
anyone could do now because it was kind
of in the way age of social media I
don't think anyone would like volunteer
but it was literally like you know on
the on one day it was like
um Auntie Johnston who's like a really
great writer comic books did um Atomic
blonde and a bunch of stuff was like
laying into the story with Karen Gillen
uh who who's lovely bloke and like so
these just these great writers just kind
of tearing apart Thomas Was Alone like
writing and me teachers teaching me
loads of stuff like on stage and then
like artists and game developers and I
think almost Adam Saltzman I think he
gave feedback like it was just basically
just this lovely kind of post-mortem
process and what's great is that was an
amazing education for me I basically
went to school for a week and just
learned from all these people who I
would never get in a room with to
discuss my work and kind of get feedback
from that's awesome and Disney kind of
reminds me of that is it's it's it's
getting into rooms with
I think I might even say this on the
show before but like getting feedback on
my narrative and like world-based
storytelling from a dude who literally
designed the queue for the Guardians of
the Galaxy ride yeah like that kind of
level of like this is a guy who has to
tell a story to thousands of people a
day you know with different languages
from all over the world convey a
narrative and kind of get the key points
and assume that a lot of people in that
queue never even saw the Guardians of
the Galaxy movie and kind of established
the rules and the law of that were all
of this stuff like having that guy give
feedback on like hey here's how you're
going to explain Tron to people like was
just like this kind of stuff it's just
it's the kind of education you can't pay
for that's the thing that again I feel
is so valuable to me personally like
we've had this conversation before where
you know I got promoted and if I were to
get promoted again I'd be like I don't
know that I want that because I just
want to write stuff yeah um you Captain
Kirk it yeah yeah but I also love that
I work with people who have way more
experience than me and that I can learn
from and that doesn't mean that I don't
disagree with things or like have my own
opinion but that I feel like there's
such a wealth of knowledge
um as the person who's become like the
writing guy at your company do you ever
feel that way like I feel like I would
hate to be
it sucks to be
it sucks to be the most kind of
experience or knowledgeable thing
honestly yeah that that person that like
that is like
yeah from a career perspective I'm a big
believer that like finding those
opportunities to learn that's the whole
point otherwise why are you doing it
like once once you've gone past that
initial excitement oh my God I made a
video game you know the thing I'm the
most knowledgeable in all of my writer's
dreams which is so lame but they did
also tell me it was um the benefit in
hiring me is that I've played the most
video games and that to be is useful to
be a well it's surprisingly useful
because I'm like oh well like this game
or someone will be like what game did
this and I'll be like this one like I
have all of the answers of every game
I've ever played uh which you never
would have thought would be useful in
Game Dev but it is actually useful but
for that to be the thing that I'm best
at is great because it's not [__]
useful like it's not actually uh a
useful skill outside of that one
writer's room you know like well well it
is it is
but that's about it
but no it's it is it is that that's why
I'm that's what I'm saying about kind of
that's one of the reasons I've been
drawn into this kind of world of doing
like licensed stuff is it just it opens
up those opportunities just go and learn
from new people that I wouldn't get to
work with otherwise and it's it's super
useful like yeah like other map my only
option is hiring talented people which I
do but obviously I'm Indie so I can't
just hire it's also a resources to
people you can't be like
my uh
that would be I would play the [__] out
on the Georgia armor yeah but he'd never
finish it if he wants it I'll give up
the IP you can take her I I I want to
play that he can have it hey hey Austin
hello Austin
I wasn't uh I was desperately trying to
work out
the the thread of where this because I
joined and the first word I heard was
writer's room and I was like ah they're
talking about the strike
a different direction yeah
I don't know how we're gonna do this
show without our Riders uh it's gonna be
a team the team matron we are non-union
the audience will already notice the
quality that's true but our writers
reunion writers who write all this
you're right so the audience may have
noticed that we're already dipping yeah
100 uh Austin we were talking about I
asked Mike what it's like to be the
writer guy and if it's annoying to be
the person in the room who is the best
slash most experienced at something but
I feel like that's also your whole job
like how often do you get to work with a
team where you learn something about
your own field
depends on what you mean by that because
for example when hiring orchestral
musicians they are routinely far more
experienced you know they're often my
parents age or older
um in many cases I mean it's a mix
there's there's Studio musicians
especially now I've reached an age where
there's also often like younger fresh
out of school members of the orchestra
and whatnot but I always liked to
conscientiously build a roster
of folks where there's people
you know perfect example one of my first
sessions 15 years ago in LA with the
Hollywood Orchestra you know I had Steve
urdodi as principal cello well here's a
guy who you know his John Williams
principal cellist for 20 years
um and and then was in the section since
the 80s uh playing on scores of his and
and not just Williams but every composer
you can think of you know every major
composer is there a specific section
that you want to get like the old hands
in is there like is there like a section
of an orchestra that's like like on the
wheel of the ship basically like it's
like as long as I've got a good cellist
I'm all right like is there that kind of
thing in orchestras or is it I mean
they're all bad right like if your
percussion's bad everybody I'm just
wondering he's like is that like yeah is
there like a safe Pair of Hands job well
first off possession won't be all right
if I've got a good programmer like if
I've got a good programmer the rest of
it can fall into place you know yeah I
don't think there's a great equivalent
to that insofar as you need everyone in
the orchestra to be great because
um
it's amazing how 80 people if if one
person is playing really noticeably Out
Of Tune even if they're way in the back
of the violins
um you'll hear it and it will actually
pull the whole thing down and so some
some positions are obviously more
damaging than others in that way like a
single violin that's not on their a game
it's gonna be
oh my gosh this is uh canvas's playlist
listen debut
yeah and right next to my very apt uh
play watch listen coaster that lives on
my desk permanently it's awesome
um yeah I don't have a coaster I don't
have a [__] coaster where's my
[__] coaster well I also have
trophies for both of you I just haven't
given you okay
I'll give you a coaster next time you
can't visit like you're gonna definitely
have some some doggy relationship I
think ASMR of her like panting even
though you can't see her totally fine um
I wonder if it would happen if banjo saw
her did we just have a dog podcast dog
off that'd be great she doesn't seem to
ever react to screens uh like huh like
if I if I pull up Angela on like a video
call
to her she's just as like I know that's
[__] I know that she's not here
that's roaring I have a friend who's a
dog will always bark at horses on
screens
every horse they could be there for a
second and he'll bark at them so Game of
Thrones is really difficult for him to
watch because the Yellowstone is
unwatchable yeah yeah I like that oh
sorry that was an aside to the aside oh
awesome yeah well yeah long and short of
it is that you don't
um this is purely subjective I really
like the way I've built the orchestra
that I've worked with here in town over
the years in terms of like choosing the
specific musicians was I really liked
the concert Master which is the absolute
like that's the team captain that's the
that's the first chair of the first
violins the one that's immediately to
the left of the of the conductor that's
the most senior position
uh well it's a historic thing concert
master was the enroll the dog the uh
yeah
um the the concert master was in the old
and olden days they were also the
conductor the first violin there was no
such thing as conductors until about the
in the modern sense there were no
conductors until the mid 1800s about 116
70 years ago yeah another industry taken
over by bureaucracy actually what it was
it was pure pragmatism because
um orchestras were small enough like if
you think of a string quartet there's
never a conductor right well there's
like a threshold where now you need
someone to act as the traffic cop it's
like lead metrics there's a certain
number of Staff where you start to need
middle layers of management yeah that's
amazing it's pretty much exactly that oh
and then when will it end initially this
is actually I can prowl on for 10
minutes but Austin can come in with like
a [__] fact
I've been writing this it's amazing
about a violinist and you've just given
me that information that now I'm like
should I need to rework some stuff I
didn't know a concert Master existed
that concert Master is always the sorry
I just searched and replaced JK Simmons
just swapped that out for uh yeah it's
always the best paid position in the
orchestra it's always usually it's
always the um it's always the most kind
of
um like there's also a certain sense of
ideally if you're looking for a change
as the conductor you would say to the
concert master
um I think we need to be a little you
know uh gentler with the way we're
coming in at bar 25 they will then go
okay here's how we're going to achieve
that
um up bow on the the note here and then
they turn and they disseminate that to
all the rest of the strings who because
if you'll notice like in a proper
Orchestra their movements are exactly in
sync with each other they're not just
playing randomly and the concert Master
is the one who's making those decisions
in fact they'll often before like a
concert not this isn't true in the
studio recording world but they'll go
through and mark the parts of the way
they I think all this ought to be done
up bows down bows Etc and that'll all
get put on the musician stands before
the first rehearsal based on the concert
Masters recommendations so that's that's
cool it's like an assistant director
it's kind of uh yeah they're sort of the
co-pilot to the conductor and so
executing the direct the the the the uh
the the plan so why is it a violinist
I I well part of it is that they are
they're right there they're immediately
next to the conductor why are they
always next to the conductive that's
just the traditional layout of the
orchestra um uh there's a lot of things
to write the whole script for you a lot
I know
she probably needs to want to be a
concert Master now
that is super interesting I didn't I had
just had no idea always driven to be a
concert Master yeah yeah it's uh you
make me uh I'll just mail you a copy of
this book
um by an author named Joan Pizer that's
basically the entire history of how the
orchestra as we understand it was over
time there's nothing science because
otherwise the orchestra
you don't need to mail it to me also if
we don't look that far apart Austin
I'm pretty sure every time I go to the
vet that I should go Heckle you yeah it
was literally like a two minute walk so
I should go to harass you whatever and
go to the bathroom I know your Works
near a really good coffee shop that's
what I that's the only thing I know
about um offline
um
the uh I know this place Porto's can't
beat the coffee oh I do know
there's also Romancing The Bean which I
quite like which is down the street
which I go to Romancing The Bean it's a
great coffee shop it's in Burbank
okay who Among Us has never been so
clearly yeah I promise that's not a
double entender well I guess it is
um so then the the
I always things that are based on
tradition rather than science are
infuriating but that's very much
this is a mix of both like it's not like
it's not it's not that the orchestra was
refined in a lab it is a product of
people iterating on something over
hundreds of years and experimentation so
they should still improve upon it rather
than just say they're here because
tradition but there's as with actual
darwinian Evolution there's a lot of
variables changing simultaneously for
example the instruments themselves
became more acoustically projecting over
time you know like modern violins or
modern meaning like the violins of the
19th century onward are much louder and
and more uh of course I say that you
know obviously the most famous violins
and best made and most valuable in the
world are a couple hundred years older
than that still cool so that's actually
a bad example let's use brass
they don't patronize us well like the
Stradivarius uh everybody knows the
strategies the average
that's worth several million dollars
Stradivarius was the name of a violin
maker in Italy yeah that would be quite
the
um Stradivarius isn't that also still a
thing that the great violin makers can
still charge like an incredible amount
of money I remember reading yeah but the
difference is like a guy who died and
like he'd been like this kind of bespoke
violin maker for 60 years and they did a
small flat in London and would just kind
of be flown around the world to make
violins for people
that's still a thing right yeah I mean
there are there are Luther you know
there are instrument makers
um who uh would you know make a like a
modern a modern violin maker of course
there's of course that if nothing else
students and blah blah blah there's a
there's a constant need for new
instruments so there are people that do
it and then as you can imagine that
there's the people that kind of
gradually rise the top as making really
good ones and and you know all by hand
and blah blah blah so yeah I mean if
you're buying a really high-end violin
as a as a pro you're going to be
spending tens of thousands or hundreds
of thousands but a Stradivarius is in
the
one to ten million kind of range like
there's a piece of a violinist would be
Austin what were the violinists do in
their spare time do you think like where
would they where were they form
relationships when you were interested
yeah if you could give us a doctor
structure that would be so helpful the
screenplay is fine except for everything
other than I don't know [__] about
orchestras and for some reason I decided
for help on this I say commit to it I
say commit to the fact that you don't do
anything do do like a post-modern like
movie where you have no idea what it
would end up reading like the old
Mitchell web sketches
you're you're you're you're you're sort
of broadly smart enough and know just
enough about this specific thing that it
will probably read like an alternate
present like it's like this is a viable
thing it's just not our world but this
is not like ludicrous it's like an old
history but specific yeah
like auditioning for this fancy
fancy orchestra that is actually
um in London I don't even remember what
the name of it but I like I looked up
the building and everything and she's
um really nervous about it in this
waiting room and I was like I'm so sure
that none of this appears this way I
don't imagine that the actual like
there's all these people walking in and
out it's like I don't know that any of
this looks like this but I wouldn't be
able to change it because it needs to
punch people nervously practicing them
yeah I have a lot of uh people tuning
instruments it was like they need to do
something I don't [__] know like I
don't know that's that's probably pretty
realistic depending on how sort of big
the orchestra but one thing to bear in
mind that's that's pretty famous uh and
especially for string auditions is but I
think they do this for every part uh for
the last half century give or take as a
way to combat racism and sexism in
hiring practices you're telling me right
now Austin is something you've said on
the show before which is the thought
that sparked the inspiration for this
entire screenplay
so co-producer they audition blind you
can't get co-producing credit if you
want you did you did Inspire the entire
thing with what you're about to say
which is that they auditioned blind it's
a yeah they put a screen master and you
have to like come in a separate entrance
and and and you know you're not supposed
to wear like high heels and things that
would immediately sound a certain way
relative to a flat-footed shoe all that
kind of stuff to make it as truly
neutral
um yeah and um
yeah I think it's awesome I mean because
it the proof was pretty immediate you
know like you know there's there you
there's there's you know most of the
orchestras that I've worked with
um both sitting orchestras and Pickups
uh tend to have pretty solid gender
parity if not
principally women uh like growing up in
my high school orchestra for example you
know there there's a few guy friends
that I I remember you know but all like
principal Viola principal cello the
flute player the timpani player I
remember it was all girls in my class
every person I know who plays Violet
ocello is a woman I don't actually know
anyone who play violin I know four girls
there may be interesting
there may be interesting like
also oddly sexist reasons for like there
may be oh I want to play sports no no
you're a girl you're gonna play violin
you know the men are all busy sucking a
guitar I imagine
men like drums uh yeah like there are
these cliches right no I think that we
do we societally do that we give gender
two hour instruments but it's funny
what's fascinating is how [__] it is
like one of the most amazing
percussionists alive on the planet is a
Scottish woman named Evelyn Glenny who
not only is maybe the most impressive
percussionist you'll ever see she's also
almost entirely deaf I was gonna say she
was big on TV when I was a kid she like
she'll be what in her like 50s now I
remember seeing her she might be older
she's she's one of those she's hard to
guess she's got a just based on how she
looks it could be a wildly wide range no
as a kid I remember her she was like the
drummer who was always on TV and yeah
she's 57. she's wow yeah so she was she
was like when I was when I was a kid she
was like a young woman kind of coming up
in her career and like she's the only
drummer I would have been aware of as a
kid she's she's I think the only she's I
think the only percussionist who has
made a solo career in the way that like
Yo-Yo Ma has a solo career with a guest
that you guessed as the Stars like
headliner with orchestras yeah no no
there's not a lot of repertoire for
percussionists as you can imagine there
are percussion concertos like there are
cello concertos and blah blah there's a
lot fewer of them and they're pretty
much all modern because that was not a
thing that composers did prior to the
20th century but um there's even then
there's still not that much because
partly there's just not a lot of stars
that orchestras would feel financially
comfortable building a show around she's
I think the only or one of she certainly
was the first
um and still one of the only what look
up her Ted talk about that she did ages
ago like in the earliest days of Ted she
gave a TED talk about about being a
percussionist and she plays a piece
written for just snare drum but in the
hands of someone on her level it sounds
like it's 20 different instruments she
gets so many sounds and so much by
vibration as well right she plays
predominantly via vibration and just
knowing and feel sensing through body
yeah yeah it's amazing like she's not I
don't think she's 100 deaf but she is
definitely I think productive hearing
that she can speak but she has that
quality of someone who can't hear their
own voice very well so it's got that
yeah I don't know what you would call
it's probably term for that but that
kind of deaf person's I can still speak
it just I don't control the Nuance of
the like the color and the Dynamics
doesn't know how she sounds yeah I think
but she's totally intelligible because
she also has a Scottish accent on top of
it
um but um uh which makes me think maybe
she wasn't deaf growing up now that I
say that because I don't know how she
would have picked up that accent if she
was born this I don't actually know her
biography I just know she's uh like as
someone who because yes there's the
cliche of like there aren't as many
women percussionists she's one of the
like you know let's see what we can do
about that stars uh because she's a
[__] inspiration
um so Austin you answered the question
of
how you don't really learn from people
is wrong because you learn from
everybody in the orchestra
follow-up to that also my my engineer my
the The Game Dev as well for sure like
you might not you I might be the most
experienced like game writer on the team
but like the best ideas usually come
from oh it'd be really cool if the
character did whatever yeah yeah I don't
think there's a good equivalent to the
programmer of like if you have a crap
programmer the game will not ship but it
but you can have like you can have
people who are still learning in other
positions and like you'll find a way to
get there I don't think there's anything
that's
quite so serious of a bottleneck in so
far as I think they all everybody has to
be able to like if your engineers it
would be like if you had to if you had
to invent the microphone every single
time you recorded yeah yeah that's the
thing like the engineer can [__] up a
session if you have a bad one the Pro
Tools operator can have [__] up a
session the conductor can [__] up a
session the members of the orchestra can
[__] up the session there's like a lot a
runner who walks in while the red light
is on can and just you hear a door open
like everybody has to know what they're
doing to it to a to a certain minimum oh
God canvas just walked through my cable
and is like I feel like I've been
Harpoon banjo often chokes himself on my
mind it's not great you're right you see
what's happening
that's amazing he's like you're done now
she's like uh this is like a The Walker
you know on hot
um all right we'll see you later Austin
listen recording where we're all podcast
hosts these days and ruined it
um outside of that Austin I just started
the show by asking Mike about a game he
had that came out since we last recorded
you have like more officially announced
a game since we last recorded we're
rehashing the lost the Lost episode
what is stray dogs
[Laughter]
because I'm in headphones so she doesn't
hear you and she thinks you're talking
to her she thinks I'm talking to her
she's like I don't understand that banjo
knows when I stopped streaming so he's
either right now he'd be asleep in the
Box camera or sleep in his bedroom and
when I go all right thank you everybody
for watching and I wave and then I pause
for a second he walks back out because
he knows that I've finished recording
she's very adorable I I was actually
really worried about having uh the the
uh like I I don't like having a bunch of
shedding hair here in the studio and
stuff I've kept it pretty clean for 10
years
um but uh on Hillary's instrument
yeah
she bumped the draw the hand drum I have
sitting on the floor very good I had to
take the uh mallets away because she
kept picking them up thinking of those I
think those are for me
um
but now I have hair in my mouth as well
yeah that's that's a whole different
vibe for this show I love it it's great
it's the we should be charging for this
it's improved now
um people missed this show they missed
this yes
we did our we did our our showcase where
we we did some live songs we kind of
explained the nuts and bolts of our
interactive music system and
demonstrated it for the crowd did you
miss that part didn't you have to be
there did you work so um yeah I remember
you were there but I didn't see each
other I was like I have a job uh so I
can't do that I I got there about just
after just before the intermission
okay yeah so then you missed our live
demonstration where it was so fun
basically my whole message with this
game has been
our cast our Geniuses that's like the
thing I care people walk away with more
than anything to do with the music or in
it because it it lives and dies by their
talents and like I've been obviously
sitting here holding my
you know tongue on who is in this game
for a year and a half uh Laura and Mary
Elizabeth McLean Laura Bailey and Mary
Elizabeth McGlynn were publicly
announced ages ago but then the fact
that Troy was uh uh playing Apollo and
not just our voice director we have
Ashley Johnson we have Anjali bimani we
have Erica ishee we have uh
Prince for ages it was like every person
I know I know it really it and
everybody's so awesome
um everyone is so like I just feel so
great Felicia uh day Janita gobankar
it's just there's so many so many great
talents Anthony Rapp Merle Dandridge
um and um
so the um the Showcase was like finally
we can put it all out there we had a we
had you know pretty much all of them
able to come do our fun you know duet
with Laura and Ashley
um and um but the live demo was let's
Troy and I will reenact a section with
Laura where all she ever had as
reference was me plunking along on the
piano or like maybe a guitar but
basically it would just be something
really basic and and it would be like
okay here's what you're going to sing
over top
um and the songs are giant tool kits of
content because they Branch like crazy
and so there's a lot of different spaces
it has to be able to go which means we
have to record all these different paths
and all these different modular bits and
you know each song has uh like like the
big songs the most elaborate ones have
literally tens of thousands of
permutations and so
um so the result is
um
that you know we'd get in a session with
Laura and it would be like okay uh we're
at measure 720 you'll recall two weeks
ago we were looking at this bit where
the immediate section prior
was if Grace does this then you know
Medusa Anjali Bomani does this so this
is what we're gonna start in now and
it's like she just has to onboard a lot
of stuff that's you know it's it's much
worse than just we're gonna shoot this
scene today and you just have to
remember where it fits in the trajectory
of a linear story like a like a movie
obviously that's a challenge enough that
that that's quite a skill already just
to shoot all out of order and have to as
an actor have to shape the character and
be like oh well they wouldn't be as
angry here because XYZ thing hasn't
happened in the story yet so I need to
temper my reaction like you need to know
where you are and obviously that's a big
part of the director helping you know
like collaborating and did Laura have to
record for
like a billion we we we uh we had we had
something like that down in my budget
spreadsheets
um we had I know I know like that's my
question as well it's just like how
because because you know me and Alana
have both been involved in my voice over
recording sessions and stuff and like I
know how much you can get recorded of
like dialogue per hour but like what's
the like what's the overall like how how
long genuinely was like an individual
performer in the studio for well it was
all sag so we were doing four hour calls
um and the question was how many
sessions we we had to start recording
before we'd finished writing the music
because we didn't know about what
average recording rate we could achieve
and that was going to affect the scope
of how much music there could be in the
game so if it turned out also it's
harder work for the performer so you can
really only do a four hour session so
yeah typically what we would do is Troy
and I would tag team where we would do
two hours of singing and two hours of
dialogue like and you know with a with a
healthy break in the middle so that
there wasn't
um uh a a um really needy today she's so
cute
um because she's helping she is very
adorable look at that smile so it wasn't
so I didn't overwhelm them and it's not
like Les Mis style it's not everything
is sung there's like dialogue I mean
there's a book as well oh yeah yeah no I
mean we had 90 sessions
um 94 hour sessions uh and and half of
those were Laura uh I mean it was it was
bananas um it's 90 times four that's
amazing it's like about a billion yeah
360 hours
um
and that's why that's massive that's
crazy yeah because all told there's the
songs are are
um like there's about six hours uh of
Music give or take
um I'm also comparing that to like sag
uh rights that's an expensive figure out
exactly how much that cost if you wanted
yeah yeah yeah that's assuming yeah
that's terrifying that's assuming any of
our casts work for scale uh and we
pretty much have all the main actors oh
right yeah that's that's if the minimum
scale yeah exactly wow yeah oh I'm I'm
factoring in Choice rights I have worked
with Troy professionally yeah but you
got some Troy weights rates you got some
Laura rates God damn I mean it was I
mean this is where a huge chunk of the
budget had to go because that's why I
was saying I mean that's really a story
in the game though right like that is
that is yeah that's your value yeah
that's why people are buying it for so
it's the right thing to do it's when you
have like crazy amounts of voice over
and that's not the song the show that
things can like escalate and you kind of
look at and go yeah what is the value
out of this yeah exactly but this is the
whole this is like you say hello this is
the story no it's so impressive like I'm
so excited to play the game
um I Liam did play a little bit of it
um in front of me at the event and uh
the the fact that each playthrough is so
distinct is a thing that we've been sold
since the beginning of time I do feel
like this particular game may have the
most variables of anything I have ever
seen before it's incredibly impressive I
mean like for example those variables
are very visible as well because of that
music because of the voiceover that's
the thing from the Lost episode Austin
Jordan like I don't know if Elon knows
about all of the stuff you're talking to
me about with like the musical shifts as
well right like these songs themselves
change genre and [__] yeah that's that
that that's what we were able to
demonstrate at the um at the Showcase
bit but like before you got there was
um
we did a song twice in a row and we
didn't have the interaction happening
live because that would have required
them to prepare and rehearsal a bunch of
[__] that we they weren't gonna end up
singing right like okay it's gonna be
one of the following five things well
that means four four fifths of your
rehearsal time as a waste so I said
let's do a mock like a three-part
stick
first we'll do a mock recording session
just to show like how Laura would have
to drop in
you're really really no I love it she's
healthy I know I know
this yeah see I'm normally very
pretentious and she's making me a you
know very very uh making a real dog dad
Vibes yeah I know I know this is a total
rebranding for me
um oh dear God she just
it's gonna be a big loud sound on the
microphone that's all right in the shop
um so we did our little mock recording
session where Troy plays director I play
composer and we show like Laura had to
just step in out of nowhere and and just
remember where we were from four days
earlier or a week earlier in some cases
you know a few weeks earlier depending
um and then from there it was okay now
we're bringing out Mary Elizabeth and
um
we'll do a path through this song
um it's kind of a big confrontation song
between grace and Persephone at the
beginning of the game and um and then it
says
um
uh then it was like okay what if you had
done different things let's show a
different path did you let the audience
choose no because you can't say
complicated
we would have had to rehearse every
possibility which we had one rehearsal
that morning for this show uh well
that's not true we did do a little run
through Laura and Ashley and Troy and
Anjali came over to the studio a couple
days earlier just to kind of if nothing
else for me to brief them on what was
coming and then we could kind of like
step through it but like with the live
instruments and all that was was once
and then okay uh doors are opening uh in
30 minutes everybody let's get roll like
so it had to streamline it as much as
possible to make their life easier
um and um so uh one thing that was cool
though that I was really happy with was
because the choices are color coded
um you know it's sort of a cousin of the
classic BioWare like you know blue
versus red dialogue tree options of you
know like in Mass Effect it's the
Paragon versus the Renegade and or it's
like Jedi versus Sith and that's the Old
Republic as a cousin of that we have our
red green blue where red is kind of like
the antagonistic and aggressive green is
sort of the
um like the uh empathic uh and and uh
compassionate and blue is the conniving
or intellectual or scheming or whatever
like especially in the context of you're
in a showdown with somebody there's
three totally different strategies by
which to deal with it which are going to
yield totally different reactions and so
in the context text of a musical number
it's not just that the lyrics are
totally different like the personality
of the of the delivery and then it goes
a lot further of like the whole genre
will change like it might be it might be
jazz versus like like driving you know
like 90s rock kind of like like a
Nirvana kind of vibe or something like
it it it's entirely based on the
Player's Choice so what we did the live
one was because it was just sung as a
song for the audience we had the
lighting cues where every time the
player would be making one of those
choices where we're at a branching point
we would change all the like flooding
colors on the stage so that you go oh
okay that's why the vibe just shifted
because the the player that's cool red
but if you close your eyes it should
just feel like a song that's telling a
story that has its bobbing and weaving
and ups and downs and so I register how
that's different for the actors singers
for you does that mean that you are
mixing two completely different genres
of song to sound like they belong
together
it's often three plus genres uh because
it evolves like there's a song that
starts off like the one we did
um as part of the performance of how it
goes live is it starts off like
bordering on Disco like it's very kind
of fast and aggressive and you know a
lot of like hi-hat
and um
um
I love how she's been so chill the whole
day and then now instant we record she's
like I'm happy about it because you've
been silent all day I guess you've just
been working and it's been can I ask a
really boring technical question are you
Banjo-Kazooie now are you basically
playing all those track simultaneous or
crossfading between them or are you
literally like have you broken things
down by like Line to Line versus the
second one no yeah because if if if we
had to make it would be far more taxing
it would actually probably break
if we had to make a discreet
um
canvas killing me I love it you're
killing me
he would never be Grant Coco is
basically what he's saying
lazy he's like I'm Batman
yeah no I mean it's it's not uncommon I
just realized I use bad joke Kazooie as
a verb in a podcast which is solid it's
it's not I forget about it it's not
uncommon to have parallel stream okay
okay
hello
do you have any treats me too you didn't
even know we're there
the problem is I'm now rewarding her for
being annoying that is true
so she's so cute
she has such an expressive face Austin
like that face
screams play yeah it's time to play
adorable you might need to go out also
yeah she may need to go a few hours ago
but
[Laughter]
I am going to
drop in the chat
an image
that you can see I would like to see it
uh let's see let me just find it oh I've
got her distracted just licking my hand
here my arm is now extremely disgusting
but hey come back over here come on
he's doing amazing he's again much
better than growing ground Coco would be
doing he's just really kind of nailing
it much better than right we never
addressed on the show that um Austin
bought me a
I forget what it's called Uh Cameo a
cameo from Grant Kirk hope to insult me
after I named my dog banjo
that's amazing yeah I wasn't gonna I
wasn't gonna Pat my own back on the show
uh quit it she's doing this husky thing
where they make these little tiny bites
they're not wearing because they have
that's very dramatic seriously look at
that face that's a that's a drama queen
that's the face you can't say no to yeah
huskies are very noisy also that it does
seem like a nightmare but thank God she
doesn't do the Husky like you know thing
that they do they're like full on Scream
thank God she does not do that it's so
funny though
it's yeah when it's not my dog
yeah yeah exactly on Instagram I love it
yeah big fan and um I'm trying to find
this damn
tweet
um oh look it's banjo
oh you want to say hi to campus
little Banger now she runs off maybe she
got jealous immediately
um that's all we need to do it's a big
doctor I am so intimidated right now by
the doorway that's intimidating
intimidating it's unavoidably scary
where in the hell is this uh oh yeah
yeah also bought me a cameo from Grant
Coke oh here we go that we never
mentioned because it was one of those
things that I watched it and was like oh
my God
what to say I think you were I think you
immediately texted me and go did you pay
for this I did yeah I was like well it's
win-win I get a support one friend by
trolling another okay you've sent me a
tweet
yeah so what's cool about this is that
is like I just love how visible that is
to the player because that's basically
like that is the structure of every
conversation like in intro Identity or
subsurface Circle any of our games but
because of the musical aspect you kind
of it becomes front and center in a way
that just isn't possible with it yeah so
there are some sort of both does this
read like there's something here that's
like Kick-Ass and Charming yeah because
the thing is
it had I realize I'm off camera um
yeah none of you are actually visible
right now anyway because I have the
Tweet up so you're fine ah so
um the whole point is that it's supposed
to be compounding so the idea is
if I chose kick ass at the beginning and
then I immediately chose Charming
there's a difference between if I did
the flip of that because totally if I
get in your face and I'm like listen you
son of a [__] and then I go you know
what that was too strong
forgive me that's a totally different
emotional Arc than
let's have a conversation and then I
don't like what you say and I go what
the [__] are you talking like so the
song can't just be this now this now
this and just slotting in a thing it has
to remember where you've come from and
tell that story which means the only way
to do this as far as I can tell is just
a [__] load of content that accounts for
every conceivable possibility wow that's
very it's like Stargate you need to know
the where you're coming from on the
destination yeah exactly audio listens I
wouldn't even really know how to
describe this but we'll say the first
option has nine parts
and then the decision and whatever's
automatic um it's super detailed and
broken down into chorus Bridge chorus 2
pre-chorus verse three
yeah because that's the other thing it
has to still feel like a song like if
it's just if it's just a constant steady
stream of new
stuff then it doesn't feel like an
actual song where you're like oh here's
the yeah here's the hook again here's
the there's that Chorus Line that I
recognize blah blah blah blah so you
have to impose structure even while
giving the player a lot of Agents how
many songs do you have does that
question make sense
in the game yeah
songs it's just that the songs have
variables right exactly no each song
exists in kind of like a Quantum state
of possible songs
um and there's uh several dozen uh like
a couple dozen musical numbers and some
of them are more elaborate than others
of course the grand finale
has literally like 70 something million
possible
ways it can play WoW
um it's pretty it's pretty bonking now
that's slightly pedantic because some of
those differences it's like just like
the joke I heard you say Mike is like
we're in an alternate universe where
everything is the same except the
orchestra is configured slightly
differently like that's basically the
same universe there are some differences
that are like that where there are
differences because things you will have
done triggered something but if you made
a lot of very similar decisions
otherwise
it you might not realize it but then
there are
at least thousands of possible decisions
that are wildly different I mean like
different characters are alive or not or
like different people like you or not
all that kind of stuff like narrative
differences core
experiential differences to the game so
Austin again I felt like this game is so
technically impressive since you first
started talking about it I don't know
however many years ago but does it
bother you it does when it comes out
that some people will only play through
it once and they will have no knowledge
of those differences
yeah well no that doesn't bother me at
all because the idea is to like the
subtitle we call it stray Gods a
role-playing musical the goal is to
encourage you to role play it's not a
scavenger hunt of find all the bits we
made the goal is also when you're making
Choice based media like it's also about
the value of the path not taken the path
not taken validates the path you took
because you chose not to go there I also
don't feel like
someone else not to choose yeah to go
down to certain quests I wouldn't I
don't mind it doesn't bother me but it's
when there's this much Choice itself a
choice I guess it isn't it makes sense
that what you're saying is ultimately
like no because what we're doing is
making sure we've made a good
role-playing game yeah we want the
choice
yeah if the choice didn't matter then
people would see most everything you
made like because obviously they
wouldn't have that much agency just by
definition so the goal was let's make it
so that because some of these saw like
like the one we did live where Grace
this main character played by Laura and
the character of the queen of the
underworld Persephone
um
uh Persephone uh played by Mary
Elizabeth McGlynn this is very
standoffish Scene It starts off in a
kind of disco sort of vibe very but like
it's like dark
sort of thorny disco which is fun and uh
depending on what Grace does
um like it can end in a very
like emotionally kind of lyrical and
very sweet way where it becomes almost
orchestral and like tragic feeling and
then there's others where like what we
showed is Grace has managed to get the
entire crowd in the nightclub where it's
taking place singing with her and it's
like this raucous over-the-top crowd
musical number
um where it it evolves over over the the
course of it well if somebody feels
moved by going down the first route
and feels like that was awesome that
they shouldn't it's like a failure to
make them enjoy it that would have them
go I just want to go back and try the
other options like obviously if they
understand the gimmick of the game they
might be curious and that's you know I
obviously we like that and of course
there's also the hope that there's a
certain amount of kind of water cooler
oh you did this oh that's how you like
how did you get it like genuinely the
biggest surprise with identity because
it's it's similarly branching and has a
lot of choices and honestly more choices
than we've done previously and I
genuinely didn't think people would want
to replay it I oh you know you hope
obviously the people won't revisit but I
thought most players would just play
their version have their choices but
everyone's replaying it it's becoming
this kind of possibility space game
it's uh I could actually look them up um
I this is entirely I could actually look
at them I always wonder how often people
actually replay games like you know
players talk about wanting replayability
considering how few even finished games
it must be a fractionally tiny so I
might be reading the numbers wrong so
this is with big caveats but it looks
like on identity of the people who've
started the people who've started the
games obviously a lot of people buy a
game on Steam and then just don't start
it so we'll remove all of them guilty
yeah I will always I will never worry
about uh respawn because they are
geniuses um so yeah so of the people
who've actually bothered to support me
as a friend those people are people
who've actually started the game about
half of them have finished which is a
ridiculously
it's it's a relatively you know it's a
shorter game and we're not talking about
40 hour experience here but like it's
that's good actually I think then
subsurf is circular
but yeah that I also think that that
yeah that the the fact that there's no
um like because Journey would be a
natural comparison here as well there's
no like fail state where you would just
have to quit like you won't get yeah
frustrated and rage quit exactly yeah
this is this is this is just yeah which
honestly this is that's good I'm really
happy with that number
um and then of those from my maths about
a third of those players then Play It
Again
so a third so one-sixth give or take of
the total player I reckon it played more
than once yeah that's gonna be way
higher normal
that's that's my point Austin like
that's what I'm seeing in like com
conversations reviews like it's
definitely one people wanna you finish
and you've made a lot of choices and
you've seen those choices play out and
you want to see if you can do it
differently and fortunately it's not
it's not uh when you're just in every
entire scenes and identity that don't
happen on your first playthrough like
you you will make you will literally not
see all of the scenes in the game if you
play it just once through yeah so yeah
so yeah
how many discreet playthroughs are
possible
but if we were doing if you if we were
doing the kind of the way you're doing
with yourself if you wanted to catalog
every it's hundreds of thousands because
you make a choice in identity like every
two minutes like so if you were to make
but it's like yours it's kind of it's a
String of Pearls so it goes out into
lots of options and then ties back
together so it's just it's a it's a few
branches few big discrete branches and
then obviously lots of micro choices
that are more about role playing and
tone
um yeah like a relative impact but yeah
yeah exactly we have we have
um that diagram you shared shows it like
you have moments where it splits apart
and then moments where it kind of comes
back together again and Etc
yeah and the all
t a little differently built based on
The Narrative desires of the song uh you
know like for example the comedic bit
with Rahul is the minotaurus
comparatively a lot simpler of a song
because it's like stuff will happen and
then he'll come back in with a thing
that we could we could repurpose a few
places because it's actually funnier if
it sounds like he's almost ignoring you
uh like there so there's bits like that
there's all those tricks you play yeah
to get the variety you have to like
because otherwise you're exactly the
Holodeck but yeah I think I think
probably like so in terms of like the
the kind of I think it was you on the
Lost podcast referred it to it as um oh
god um Borderlands maths with
Borderlands maths was it you said that
like where it's basically like all the
gun oh must be someone someone else must
use that phrase recently for me they're
kind of the permutations of guns there's
millions of guns in Borderlands but it's
because of the combinations with that
kind of maths we're talking hundreds of
thousands of like playthroughs to get
like possible play for his identity I
reckon if you played the game through
like six or seven times you could see
every line of dialogue but you'd have to
work hard to like
choose make your choices to get through
the right paths in order to see actually
no that's not true there's no be more
than that'd be like nine or ten but yeah
anyway it's um so yeah no it's good but
that's I'm actually I'm glad I looked up
those numbers
yeah the Borderlands actually is a great
I didn't come up with that and I will
start using that as an analogy to
explain but yeah we should be clear I'm
not throwing shade on Borderlands but
like yeah
yeah no it just clarifies the difference
of like there's choice is not a single
maps and Borderlands Maps
like well because there's there's
choices that will fundamentally change
the gaming experience in a in a deep
rooted way and then there's changes that
are like cosmetic and have no impact and
then there's changes that are kind of in
between those where they have an impact
and you might feel it and like oh I like
playing with this gun more than that
other gun but the the the sense of the
story the characters won't be changed so
I think the vast majority of stray Gods
changes are
the really highly impactful and that
middle Zone we don't really have an
equivalent to
um like play exactly the same but this
gun instead of that gun
um but we do approach that but there but
the thing is they're all second order
effects based on what you do like for
example yeah one of the things that we
explained on the night of the event was
that um I'm I create instrumental
associations with the color choices so
that for example every time you choose
red at every point in the game you will
hear an electric bass so that there's
like a pavlovian sense of oh I did a
thing and something predictable happened
because that's obviously very important
from a design standpoint that if I do a
thing it shouldn't just feel like
something happened I seemed like let's
make the songs have some degree of
predictability so the sound the actual
the actual presentation of it will be a
thing that you can predict with complete
certainty once you see this is what's
going on that you get you get clarinets
with uh blue you get harp with green you
get electric bass and they are
prominently featured instruments
separate from whatever is going on
lyrically in genre and blah blah blah
narratively et cetera et cetera so
that's one of those tricks where we're
able to make it where
uh like you saw in that diagram on the
thing some of the decisions will fold
you into where if you want to choose
something else you have to have made a
different decision earlier because it's
compiling several and you can track that
particularly by listening to the
instruments that are playing where
you're going oh I didn't click red but
I'm hearing red because I've like been
swept momentarily down a red stream but
that doesn't have to have been that way
it could have been a green stream or a
blue stream or that kind of thing so
there's a lot of complexity where to me
that's more noticeable than just I have
a scope on my gun versus not
but it's not the same thing as you know
if I pick character a versus character
B1 will die yeah you know what I mean uh
so the game it's it's a combo of things
that you'll notice and and make
they make experiential differences and
then there's others that like make core
gameplay differences
um and yeah even if you're really strict
in how you draw those fences there's
like
just thousands and thousands and
thousands of possible playthroughs so
impressive very cool I can't wait to
play it when to come out Austin August
3rd August uh we're still we're still in
our uh
like would you say the players who want
to have a similar experience between now
and then should pick up Tron identity on
Stevenson is that a thing that you would
say Austin
I would say that yeah
you you plucked it right out of my would
you could you say literally what I just
said please
I think that uh I think Tron identity to
wet your appetite for the the uh to be
clear that you've not played yeah
irrelevant you don't need your friends
no but but actually it is funny how they
are really kind of uh genetic cousins in
so many regards
um and uh inspiration to you right well
I mean look I remember when I first
played uh subsurface quarantine uh
because you had quite a bit more such
game exists you mean subsurface circular
records quarantine sir wait what he
played both of them he's combined the
two of them what is the sequel what is
this like quarantine's actual name I
always [__] it up there's subsurface
circular and quarantine circular oh see
thank you so much that was the modular I
played them both
one that had the more elaborate
branching that's true where I watched on
YouTube somebody there was an ending
that I genuinely I I had to go back and
go where did that
sort of juncture occur because I could
not figure out
how they got that and so watching
somebody else oh you believe that was a
limitation of quarantine circular yeah
no but I liked that that made me
intrigued because I just chose what I
thought was right and then I saw an
ending I thought was cool and I was like
well wait a minute what did I what would
I have had to have done that would have
been a suspension of my normal instincts
in order to get this yeah this outcome I
like and that to me is a very
interesting type of game design
um and so you're not wrong to call uh
you what you do and you're just you
incarnate an inspiration because that's
the kind of stuff that we thought okay
since we don't have gameplay mechanics
separate from this it's not like oh we
also have this super [__] awesome
crafting system or something this better
be [__] deep this better be worth
going through and and you know there
will be a lot more stories to tell when
it actually comes out but uh it's been
so much fun and like I said that the
night of the thing that the broken
record that I was was just working with
this cast has been a career and life
highlight like Laura is superhuman
watching Troy I wish he was here to well
actually it's probably good that he's
not because he would have been
interjecting to steer me off of just uh
foaming at the mouth but watching him
direct was amazing uh like truly
genuinely he's so good at it we're all
like positive things to say about
working oh he was so much fun to work
rahu was such a joy it was such like he
made he made it very clear that he was
coming in a bit apprehensive of like I'm
probably gonna make an ass to myself
but um this is a singing role yeah they
must have done a musical episode of uh
iZombie
he danced I I he did theater for a long
time so I wouldn't be surprised if he
had yeah at some point but um not in a
long time
he he is a uh I think I mean it's fun
hearing different play testers different
standouts because obviously David Gator
coming from Dragon Age like
people debate about oh this romance is
the best and a lot a lot a lot of you
know as with Mass Effect a similar thing
that was very much the goal to achieve
that here like are you you did what
that's ridiculous this is the best
version you know like the goal is to
hopefully get people really excited
about the choices that they made
um and therefore there should hopefully
be a bunch of different standout moments
but I will say Rahul is consistently a
standout moment because he's just so his
character is so funny like he's it's
actually a very well I I I'm getting
ahead of what I'm probably supposed to
say pre-launch but he's very funny uh
and just yeah he's he crushed it uh for
a for a character that wasn't don't tell
him though alone can you not tell him no
no he'd be insufferable oh terrible can
you imagine what is he the main
character well System Shock Twitter
account was the main character of
Twitter yesterday I don't use Twitter
anymore what happened they yeah they uh
they like had posted up a bunch of like
AI generated art and were like going
down there
yeah system track 2 was definitely when
it came out to me like blew my mind I
thought it was absolutely incredible and
it's way way more of the immersive Sim
in the Deus Ex vain than Bioshock is far
more of a shooter right which is
probably why it's also far more
successful it's it's a lot more sort of
like it's a little bit simpler
emotionally appealing yeah I never
realized until kind of recently that
System Shock 2 was actually a bit of a
commercial failure it was like a hundred
thousand some odd units or 200 000 units
which blew me away because when I played
it I was like this must surely be like
the Game of the Year to everyone ever uh
it just was so compelling to me
strongly in agreement symptoms
everybody of System Shock that I'm
actually not sure if this is a
re-release or a remake I need to look
into it they did a Kickstarter for one
right I know it's it's coming out on May
30th
I hope it's good cool
yes wow yeah I I didn't realize that was
coming out so soon I remember first
hearing about that ages ago and I just
assumed it kind of died on the vine I
forgot all about it well see you're the
part of the reason that System Shock 2
didn't sell well Austin
let's go make uh Jurassic Park
trespasser didn't they they taste it
yeah 100 because they had to keep Studio
the greatest video game ever made oh 100
I actually love almost every Jurassic
Park video game I'm not gonna lie
um Sega CD from the mid 90s I never had
a Sega CD no remember the Game Boy one
which had like scenes from the book
because it was made before the movie so
like it was like all the stuff from the
book rather than film but clearly they
didn't have access to the script for the
movie
the Sega CD game I play the [__] out of
because I would rent it uh from
Blockbuster and it's just so janky I was
watching a capture on YouTube of it but
it does look really bad oh it's so bad
and as as happens with so many Sega CD
games it has all these FMV like
interstitials oh yeah with Bad actors
who are like giving you your mission and
then you go back into the world because
the whole premise of it is that like
after the events of the movie you're
supposed to go back to the island and
get a bunch of eggs like to kind of
finish the mission that that nedri
started except you're one of the good
guys because of course those bad guys do
show up and you have to end by shooting
bad guys instead of just dinosaurs yeah
and um and it's just one of those really
really silly
um like but the thing that's so funny is
they have these FMV
actors
um but it's in that it's in that it's in
that little sliver of time where the
tech is supporting that and therefore
you can do audio playback but the
budgets are still quite low so it's all
like really bad midi music that sounds
absolutely nothing like the the the sort
of aesthetic of Jurassic Park it's a lot
closer to like you know 80s like Metroid
you know kind of classic chiptunes
acceptance yeah well I feel it yeah and
I feel like people don't realize that
music would license stuff there is a
good reason why licensed games often
don't actually have like the John
Williams score it's because it's a John
Williams score and and those rights
aren't necessarily fully owned by any
one particular yeah or they cost license
games
astronomically expensive yeah yeah
exactly yeah like it was it's notable
that LucasArts
pretty much always until after 2000 you
just reused the John Williams
scores like especially after CD-ROM
uh and we could play back uh audio and
you weren't just doing live Hardware
synthesis like 8-bit 16 yeah chipsets uh
you know like you think of playing
X-Wing Alliance For example or or or uh
Shadows of the Empire whatever it's just
they're literally just dragging and
dropping the oh yeah the original films
recordings so it's ironic that's the
power of the Star Wars soundtrack right
it's like but how funny music and it's
half your production value that's the
thing especially comparing it to other
games at the time where it's all
original music they don't have anywhere
like these are London Symphony Abbey
Road you know you don't and then you
like shift over to you know a different
you know
trying to think of a comparable game
and um uh you know Mario 64 or something
totally different vibe uh because they
you know and uh all actually that's
probably not a great comparison because
still compositionally so excellent
um but just far a far cry from the
London Symphony in my in my in my space
Sim
anyway I see here an AI
using AI to imagine what AI would look
like
I just said you it's the system you see
the system shop tweet here which went on
I can understand it did not go down well
so their first tweet is System Shock uh
look at you hacker a pathetic creature
of meat and Bone your body weak fragile
how can you challenge me a perfect
machine imagine how would My Immortal
body look like great sentence designed
by a model machine for a model machine
which is like an AI generated image that
quote tweet um is really the problem
which is them saying an AI using an AI
to imagine what AI would look like in
physical form doesn't get more matter
than that which was the entire point of
starting the conversation no it wasn't
you got in trouble for sharing AI art
In fairness to them that's the one game
not the one but it is a game where it
actually is a on topic conversation uh
that's that's that is true that's fair I
mean like they may have actually had
very pure and innocent intentions and
just been oblivious to the fact that
they made it sound like they were trying
to get a lot of people riled up and I
don't buy that
I think that was a mistake I'm not
crying you're crying yes I'm not I'm not
trolled your trolled yeah what are you
doing back there
oh good yeah thumbs up all right hey
um before we wrap up uh Austin do you
have any brief thoughts on Jedi Survivor
um
I
I have been quite enjoying it uh I think
some of the issues I hear
I largely agree with but they're not
deal breakers for me you know like the
platforming could be really cumbersome
uh and there's like a lot of okay midair
Dash jump to this thing wall run do the
thing and I don't love that ninety
percent of the time my payoff is for a
lightsaber thing that has no actual
gameplay impact because I can't not
cosmetics
it's pretty much all like it's seemingly
80 percent are outfits for you bd1 or
lightsaber uh the lightsaber and I think
that's cool
um but the fact that that's the majority
I don't love that because I know that
I'm the type that when I see the map and
it goes 97 discover I'm like
[__] I can't not go get the
stuff
um and so I do feel like it's more
traversal heavy than the previous game
well it's because it's practically an
open world
design I mean it's huge and yeah that
part is I'm a little mixed on that and
I'm a little mixed on
um the
um
the like I I was watching the skill up
review and he was pointing out how like
the enemy
uh composition is a bit sort of
schizophrenic we'll have like Legions of
very easy to kill droids and
Stormtroopers and stuff and then these
creatures and stuff that can pretty much
one shot kill you
um and there's not a lot of Middle
Ground I I enjoy when it's a challenge
like I will I will I will you know like
it's actually fun it kind of gets that
that style pretty well for me but so
it's like I look at it I go is this
flawless
uh no there's a lot of little things
also I have been playing it on a pretty
top of the line gaming PC and it crashes
all the time yeah the frames are real
bad the performance issues that people
complaining about I felt them I noticed
that if I if I if I launch the game with
the continue button it will crash on
launch 100 of the time but if I manually
load it seems to be fine
that none of that has stopped me from
playing and look here's the thing above
or above all it feels like real Star
Wars in a way it feels like a classic
Star Wars like LucasArts 90s game
um beautifully like it does the Star
Wars World immersion so well
um and it's like it's like you mix it
with Andor and the previous one followed
order and Rogue one and that's like
those are like the Four Star Wars things
in 20 years that I think
hold their own to Classic Star Wars like
to me I feel like I'm in a Star Wars
thingy and I love that they do
they they they do the best version of
what Star Wars always did which is let's
take something familiar
uh and then mix it with a bunch of new
stuff and also maybe give it a variation
like this is not really a spoiler
because one of the very first things to
encounter but I love the fact that you
immediately encounter
um droid army like Clone War clone troop
uh Droid Troopers you know the little
Roger Roger guys because they're so cute
but they're not they're not separatists
they are a derelict that was discovered
by basically like Mad Max style pirates
that realized oh we can program these
guys to be our minions so you get a like
they're all painted with war paint and
stuff and I'm like that's a way to take
the familiar and then put it in a way
that's totally fresh you've got your
little familiar you know looking enemies
you hear those voices again but it's a
totally new context and so it doesn't
feel like mindlessly just giving us oh I
see it's it's a rehash of this or that
or that it's really not but it's it's
making it feel fresh without making it
feel too different uh do you think Troy
will ever get off Coruscant
I actually thought about that the other
day I was playing the game and I just
randomly burst out laughing alone here
in my room because I was like I was like
boy I've come a long way since that
train that opening sequence in the first
one is one of my favorite like video
games Star Wars moments of all time I
played that last night I'm I'm replaying
falling order and yeah
to prepare for Jedi Survivor which I
also really like but I actually don't
like how open it is um
that's my concern with the reviews
because I love the Fallen order kind of
I love that like Dark Souls light style
structures yeah me too I also I also
like that but I I was saying this I
think on Twitch yesterday that
the open wild sections also have a lot
of like screen tearing and frame rate
problems and for what like when what
you're saying is correct that I just end
up getting anxiety when it's open
because I don't know what I've missed
and where
that I'm just like oh there's probably
stuff here that I need to go find every
single thing here but it doesn't
actually bring me enjoyment it brings me
anxiety because I'm like what if I step
in the wrong direction and get triggers
cutscene oh no uh but I love the combat
I think the combat feels awesome I think
the traversal mechanics are much more
smooth like I love that you have all
your abilities from the jump rather than
it being like Oh for some reason Cal
can't force push anymore
um that that's actually not to be under
appreciated I think like because so many
sequels have this like Star Wars or
magic type games you know where you have
to like learn a power
they constantly have that problem where
how do you how do you start over a SQL
how do you onboard the play I love that
they're just like yeah you just you you
have the four like I think the framing
was how do you go from Jedi Knight to
Jedi Master or something like that which
I was like that's a great design
uh sort of North Star yeah you know
really uh yeah that I think we also made
cal a more interesting character too
he's he's pretty
um
playing I guess in the first game
um in in this one they gave him some
more attitude I also major shout out to
the the actor that plays Greece I pretty
much love every word out of that guy's
mouth
um he has this kind of he has this kind
of like quasi Danny DeVito characters
man I just I just love him I just I
loved him in the first one and and
because he's sarcastic but then he'll
have these moments of real
heart you know where he's like and he's
like things are going to be okay kid and
it's just you I'm like boy the actor had
like one line to to make me feel
something and they stuck The Landing
yeah I think all of them the woman who
plays Marin as well I also consistently
really I loved her in the first game I
haven't had I'm only I'm guessing
halfway or between a third and a halfway
through so I haven't yeah
well I think that's probably if you
Mainline it it's probably 20 hours if
you if you're the idiot who has to find
every [__] chest it's probably it's
surely more than that because I think
I've put in close to 20 and
I definitely am not near the end it is
really hard not to
it's again it's a struggle
um all right we're back everybody thanks
for watching this episode of play watch
listen I'm going to play some video game
right now let's make with these video
game director that's Austin wintry and
canvas both of whom are video game
composers we heard her play the Tantrum
she heard it here better than Austin if
I'm honest I've never heard him play it
so he probably could canvas all over the
place yeah
um I love that you feel the need to
demonstrate
[__] watch me I have actual mallets
she can't she just she doesn't have you
know
it's to be fair I just stopped her from
chewing them and destroying she was
trying to play with them play us out
Austin play us out
give you a nice sort of gathered here
today exactly exactly Troy had a meeting
[Music]
Troy had a meeting that he went to it's
not normally uh it's not normally used
this is not normally how we would use it
but I like I just love the the now we
want you children's television
that is what I'm good foreign
orchestras are slightly different
[Music]